foreign
we're going to go to Sandy in South
Dakota hey Sandy how are you
good how are you good what's going on
all right so I just finished a residency
um so I start my first real doctor's job
on Monday that's awesome thank you thank
you so my salary is going to be 200 000
um and then there's you know
um bonuses and all that later
um but I am currently in debt
287 thousand dollars
um uh the all Federal loans that I do
have five thousand dollars in credit
card debt but with no interest
um and I plan on just paying that off
like right away my first paycheck and 8
000 and savings because I saved up some
books um I saved up I saved up to 12 000
total because of my move and the fact
that I had like two months off between
residency and my next job so now I have
like 8 000 left of that
so my question is
um
do I stick to the Public service loan
forgiveness that I'm currently on
because I'll be out of VA hospital I
have 27 out of the 120 payments towards
it
you know with the possibility of paying
a lot less of my loans if I go through
that route for
um 10 years
but the issue is if I don't stay at a
non-profit hospital or at the VA I will
lose that
or do I end up just paying it off in you
know three to five years aggressively
um that way with 3.5 interest if I
refinance through Sofi yes well number
one congrats Dr Sandy I'm so excited for
you
um here's yeah so with these debt
forgiveness programs a lot of them
really cause you to be handcuffed to
something right you're still like that
you're not in a different way and when
you're not having the freedom to choose
a different spot so if you wanted to
leave the VA Hospital like you said you
lose it all so what you're doing is
you're kind of giving power
to someone else when it comes to your
money and the debt versus you saying I
can just clean this up and I can link it
up quick because the great awesome thing
too Sandy is 200k you're starting out
which is amazing so number one I would
not do the debt forgiveness program I
would pay this off so that you're not
attached to something for 10 years of
your life not just the debt but also the
career and where they're where they're
making you work in that instance and I
mean even with the 5K
and credit card data I love that you
said we're going to pay that off
um you're gonna have to have a lot of
discipline Sandy because you are about
to make two hundred thousand dollars
and there's a thing they always say is
docitis right you go out and get a nice
car you're making all this money and
you're done with school you're ready
just to enjoy life well I plan to drive
my Mazda
3.12. yes okay so Sandy I mean just
looking at the at the math I'm like you
could be completely out of debt in 18
months if you lived on like 30 40 000 a
year which people do all the time yeah
and you just sacrifice and you do you
live in Sioux Falls is that where you
are
that's where my new job will be okay
which is amazing too I'm like that from
a from an
um a cost of living standpoint you're
not in Manhattan you know you're not in
San Francisco like you're in a great
place to literally live on nothing Sandy
for for 18 months two years and you can
have almost you have almost 300 000 in
student loan debt gone like I mean I
look at the math when I first you heard
you say to 200 you know 287 000 I was
like oh no but then you said I'm gonna
make 200 I was like brilliant perfect
but you have to have the discipline
Sandy but you can do this you can
absolutely get this debt knocked out and
then the beautiful thing is once that's
done
you have 200 Grand that you're going to
make in the next year that's yours
they're like should I so what I'm afraid
of is like once I refinance and don't
have my government loans anymore I'm
scared like what if I lose my job and
then I'm stuck with
the the payments I'm forced to pay it
whereas I just keep the government of
Federal loans and don't refinance it
what's the refinance what's the rate
what would you get difference is that
3.5 okay and you would go down to what
no sorry
um so the government is about six
percent and so five days and three
people honestly Sandy the the interest
stuff that isn't even that big of a deal
because it's not going to be that long
well and there's there's no sign that
you're going to lose your job that's a
scarcity mindset that like out of
nowhere you're gonna lose your job like
we could we consider and do run what if
scenarios all day but you have
absolutely no evidence that you have any
reason to lose your job so we're just
going to go based on what you know today
which is you have a job and you're
making good money
and I wouldn't get all twisted up about
about the interest honestly because
again if we were talking about eight
years of this then yeah that's something
we're talking about 18 months or I am
yeah so it's not it's not even gonna
really make that huge of a difference
over that short period of time yeah
Sandy you can do this it's going to take
the discipline for the season just like
we're talking about but it's going to be
worth it on the other side of this when
you have this incredible income and
you're not having to make those payments
the thing that's interesting though
Rachel that I think some people miss and
we talk about this all the time when we
talk about money we're not just talking
about money we're talking about what
money can do for you the options the
power the control the possibilities the
future that you have because when you
have money you've got all kinds of
options when you have stuff you don't so
the reason that I love that we want
Sandy to get out of debt so quickly with
her taking control of all of it is
because then she has options if you keep
doing this government program you have
no options and you are in debt just in a
different way it's not Financial but
you're indebted to them and you're stuck
with them you have no 10 years yeah yeah
no no options no power no control and we
want you to have all the options all the
power all the control that's why we
teach what we teach so you got this
Sandy and you call back when you're debt
free because I want to hear your debt
free screen